so we are going to cooperate communicate
and to work out a
solution is in our region based on our
national
competence
on the ground of national security and
basically from my understanding from my
viewpoint i would very much welcome
such uh
decisions in
coming days coming weeks where we
will
in full accordance with schengen visa
code a ban entry of
of
to our national territories of these
people who
of russian federation
not
in making any difference either they do
have estonia issued or second
schengen country issued schengen visa i
will be satisfied today when
russia loses ukraine wins but to put it
to the realistic perspective so
my approach i would be
as a best option in that particular
issue
look would see as an pan-european ban to
russian citizens well we got
this outcome that
council members made a pledge to
european commission to look after what
we should do with these millions with
masses of visas issued what they should
do
well yes we agreed on on
on
well freezing the
visa facilitation program
but
but indeed in these practical issues
about physical band of entry this we
need to work in the regional
level this is a reality but
when we started that debate some weeks
ago
well of course now it's the issue is on
the table and that is i'm happy